project cars might be as famous for its
unique but controversial world of mass
development crowdfunding scheme as it is
for its racing pedigree and after a
five-month delay that pushed the game's
release date back to March of this year
we're as curious as anyone to see
whether this multi-platform racer
possibly live up to its promise of being
the next gen racing experience that
gamers have been desperate for and then
we remembered we're not racing drivers
and also that half the team don't even
have driving licenses so armed with a
ps4 preview copy of the game and a
Thrustmaster t500 RS steering wheel
we've enlisted the help of GameSpot
sister site ex car and it's trapped
train drivers to help us find out if
project cars can compete with the very
best racing Sims or if this one's for
the arcade nuts only I don't play a huge
amount of racing games anymore I used to
play a lot more but I do really enjoy
them and especially in the office we
always have a an ex car challenge on a
Friday with the thrust master usually on
Gran Turismo 6 actually we play a lot
about the moment so we do a sort of
appreciate the driving simulator side of
video game
it's really difficult racing simulators
because really it's so far removed from
the actual process of driving a car
because you haven't got the fear you
haven't got dicks or precognition
simulators when you lose it on these
games in a corner
you only notice through the visual
indication usually and by that point
it's too late in a real car when you
start to slide
there will be inputs of your and you'll
be feeling it in the sort of the seat of
your pants yeah it's something you feel
with your butt basically and you can't
really get that sitting on a an office
chair at the moment
I am the causes for XCOM we make videos
about cars on the internet I have had a
racing trainer yet I've done my my odds
test which means I am now licensed to
race on a race track in Britain in
certain series and then if I do more
races I can upgrade that and eventually
race in Formula One all the MOL and that
is the plan in fairness to project cars
I've never driven an LM p1 car so I
can't really say for definitive that it
handles entirely accurately but you know
what as they go this there is a
sensation speed which is great the
braking is as one would expect from a
race car is either on or off no matter
how much you feather it you've gotta be
really careful with it saying the
throttle the tolerances are super tight
which you'd expect from a race car and
it does do that thing where if you
decide to be a little bit stupid in a
corner and maybe lift off the throttle
when you balanced it or put a bit too
much on it will spin and you will look
like a [ __ ]
actually I found it a lot more difficult
than Gran Turismo it was a lot more
unpredictable which I imagined a real
lmp1 car would be the most rewarding for
us if it's really difficult to drive
it's sort of a challenge to to nail that
one lap I think actually the physics are
amazing and I think they have the
potential with this early version to be
up there with Gran Turismo if not
slightly surpassing them in terms of
what's available at the moment I think
this is really up there I was really
impressed
I wasn't bowled over by the graphics in
there they're nice enough but that's not
what I've seen in the trailers so I'm
hoping this is like super the sound
however is brilliant they've gone to the
effort of recording proper engine noises
because something I've noticed for Gran
Turismo is that you can drive say a jag
VA and then jump into an Aston v8 or a
bend of the v8 and they sound quite
similar each engine has its own
different characteristics and they are
very very different
that sounds amazing the gearbox its
proper racing Gibble's when you actually
look is look we can work with it sounds
like a proper racing car
I'm gun I want to play more of it I want
to see it a bit further on the line that
it from that there is definite promise
to be something that's going to make
gran turismo make a little bit child's
play